members of the FIFA Executive Committee
are part of one of the most powerful and
opaque entities and sports each time
they get together as with this meeting
in March the smiles betray no answers to
questions from waiting journalists
they're the 25 members guiding the
governing body of world football their
president Sepp Blatter and one vice
president on the committee Michel
Platini are this meeting banned by the
FIFA ethics committee from taking part
24 executive committee members are
appointed by worldwide football
Confederations and associations and they
in turn elect a president collectively
they determine the movement of billions
of dollars coming in from TV and
sponsorship deals and the awarding of
World Cups is determined by them until a
few years ago appointments to the
executive committee were considered
lifetime appointments ISA Hayatou from
Cameroon for example has been with the
committee since 1990 he's just become
the acting head of FIFA since Blatter
has been sidelined by the ethics
suspension hayat to offered a rare peek
inside the walls of the institution as
he assumed the reigns whether intended
or not the membership of now his
executive committee has seen eight
resignations in the last five years that
were due to corruption allegations
several others have left and new members
have been put forward as of the first of
this year that may sound like renewal or
a renovation of the old and a hugely
influential committee but critics don't
believe there's real change of foot far
more radical movement is needed they say
to save and restore FIFA's credibility